hey guys this is andrew for chatting
sensors.com so let me quickly introduce
myself for those who don't know me at
i've been working as a professional
trader on the option market for the past
six years in hong kong
and i've decided to create my youtube
channel a few months ago
because i want to pass the knowledge i
want to show you how protraders are
actually working
how we do our analysis what kind of
tools and techniques
we can use to make money on the markets
so if you want to know about all the
stuff
you guys are in the right place so today
i want to make an update on
gamestop gme technical analysis let's
get into it
[Music]
so this is my chart for gamestop so the
first thing let's start on the four
hours time frame
don't worry we don't need all this
drawing but i like to keep it because
it's actually helpful guys
to predict what will happen so i like to
keep my old
drawing and to you know just adapt to
what happens
so here i was saying so i'm on the
forward time frame only look here guys
this is what is happening right now this
is what is interesting
i was telling you guys that the 50
period moving average
was containing the price and that this
is the resistance
we have and right now i saw something
else so first you can see that it acted
very well
until the 1st of april here we have
this open that was very very low but yes
you can see that there was no breakout
of this
resistance for breakout to occur we need
to have two consecutive candles
on the time frame we're looking at that
are closing above this resistance level
so here we have one but the second one
for example the green one you can see
so this is the resistance level guys the
50 moving average
i identified this resistance level here
guys and
you can see that until now it is
working we have not broken it yet when
we will
things will change you're gonna see for
now we are turning below
here we trade above one time but
right away guys we we correcting and
which
we close below here same thing we close
below we close below and we are now
training uh below so guys this is this
one you need to look at all right so
here we close above here below
and i expect this to continue to act as
a resistance
as long as we are trading below this
level
now what else can we see on this chart
something that i put here in orange guys
it's a descending
triangle so descending triangles usually
occur
in fourth waves here it's actually in
the second wave all right
so very quickly iliot wave counting
is showing me this one two three four
five
so and then we go probably to 480 on the
three four five the third one is going
to be the most impulsive one
all right we're doing a two this is not
what i want to show you right now guys
but um keep this in mind you're gonna
see this one two three four five uh
happening i think very soon but for now
we are doing a triangle all right so
it's a second wave for me of this new
impulse that is starting
so what are we looking for uh we're
looking for
either we break the 160 level on the
short term
which is probably gonna mean that
i was wrong somewhere here i'm gonna
adapt and i'm gonna
um you know just show you what i see uh
if this happens but
i don't think it will happen i think
that 160
is gonna act as a short-term support
once again our long-term support is 170.
i need to change the time frame to use
this one but
you won't see a daily close below 170
in my scenario you can see uh four hours
close but not
a daily close so that's why it's very
important guys to switch
from one time frame to the other one and
not using the same trend lines and
same support and resistance we have
support and resistance
for each time frame here on the four
hours time frame i have
this one so 160 is my support level
and here i have my downward sloping
trend line which i really like to use
guys they are working very well
i showed you guys how this worked out
very well here
you see we broke it we retest it and we
go higher all right
this is how those downward sloping trend
lines are working
so when you identify one and you can see
that here
the price is contained in this triangle
usually associated with volumes going
lower we're gonna have a look at that
then you know that this all makes sense
and that you are probably correct about
what you are uh saying so here what i'm
saying is that the price is going to
keep contained
and suddenly there's going to be a
breakout so either on the downside which
i don't believe for all the reasons i
showed you guys in all my videos
so i believe it's going to be a breakout
on the outside so something like this
all right maybe
okay break out re-test we go higher this
is going to be the third wave
now to finish on this video guys i was
just talking about the volumes and the
volumes are very
important guys to look at especially on
a stock like gamestop and i showed you
guys this already
in my previous video i here can identify
a pattern all right that is quite
obvious
is that before each move up you know
you have this kind of early signals of
volumes going higher than lower and
suddenly we have a breakout but then you
see we have something like this and
look at this game uh strong volumes
associated with a very strong bullish
momentum appearing in the market
and then volumes going lower when the
price action
is getting lower right this is meaning
that we are in a healthy correction that
the price action
should uh keep going higher that we're
probably gonna have some continuation
patterns
and that they're probably gonna give us
some bullish
signals here we have the same thing guys
and you can see
the time is actually making sense as
well
one month roughly between 25th of jan
and 25th of feb and then all right the
25th of march we had
this an early signal so you know we
could have done something like this all
right
and then it would be perfect but i
prefer to do it like this because
here we have this strong and once again
the bullish day
that we had on the recovery from the 30
drop
we had on the earnings on 24th of march
the bullish day was the one
associated with the high volumes alright
so this is bullish again
and here i expect actually the volume to
kick in
again guys and when they're gonna kick
in it's not gonna be a bearish day i
don't believe it because the paris days
have low volume so i believe we're gonna
have a strong bullish day
i believe it's when we're gonna break
out from this triangle
that is in orange here and that is gonna
push the price higher probably around
the 300
400 area i'll show you guys that we have
a very important expiry day once again
we have expiries coming every month
so it might be not this one but
something is telling me that this one is
going to be huge
uh because i have all the other
indicators that are
decanting me that something big is going
to happen
so i believe it's going to be on the
upside and i showed you guys once again
that if we go close to 400
we're gonna have some short positions
beared by professionals that are close
to what they were
when we had this first squeeze so this
is a level where a squeeze might
happen again so let's find out
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
if you did please don't forget
to click on the sub like and bell button
so you can be the first to know when
upload anything
new and stay close to show i see you
guys